- Look at the snow coming.
That's pretty.
It's going to get
colder and snowier.
Look at this.
Let's check out the sky first.
Totally white.
No sun today, Mongolia.
I love this first
snow, being in it.
I wasn't in it the last time.
This is what I've been
expecting for a couple of weeks.
I didn't expect to be as
warm as long as I was.
I'm grateful for it.
But this.
Today is the day it feels
like the season started.
And I mean the season of alone.
Now it feels like it started.
I just saw a fish
jump over there.
Maybe I can get
some action here.
I think it's about
time do some fishing.
[water rushing]
I remember a week ago,
I was thinking fishing
might be done for
the season, not
because the fish don't
bite, but because
of my accessibility to them.
I guess the time of season
dictates what fish you're
going to be at certain spots.
I thought they would go deeper
if I could walk further,
but I can't, really.
No.
I'm not going to chance it.
The water is really moving here.
Got one.
[water rushing]
It appears I found a spot in the
river that the fish are active.
OK.
I was already in a good mood.
This puts me in a better move.
If I ever deserved to
catch a fish, it was today.
Guess what today is?
Today's day 35, which is a good,
solid number in and of itself,
but it's a milestone
number for me
because in Patagonia on
day 35, I was calling
them to come pick me up.
I knew in the middle
of the night on day 34
that I was going to be
calling them on day 35.
I was not in nearly as good
a state as I am right now,
and I'm extremely
happy about that.
Five weeks is pretty good, even
though I didn't feel that great
about it at the time.
But now I'm at five weeks,
man, and I'm rolling.
I'm in a groove.
And I'm not cold
and I'm not sad.
Lonely?
At times.
I mean, not really.
I miss my family.
But I don't know if that
classifies as being lonely.
You know, I'm not like sullen
and downtrodden and like,
man, I really want
to see my family.
I really do, but
I'm not like, oh no.
What am I going to do?
I know they're
there waiting for me
and it's going to be all
good, so I'm all good.
So it's all good.